Har du någongång varit med om att ni har ett riktigt stort reklamupplägg på G och så kommer ut en artikel om Sveriges sämsta SEO-byråer och så råkar den byrån vara i topp som du skulle göra reklam.
Det är hem då?
Jaha, fan vad roligt.
Men är det så, nu gick vi in, du ska få berätta lite om dig själv, men jag bara hoppar in här lite.
Det är rätt sjukt att ni, vad sa du, omsökt en 160 miljoner.
Jag är ju Chernobyl-generationen, jag kan inte ta, du vet, vem är du typ?
Det låter inte så jävla verkligt.
Du har redan dess bra ord.
Ni har inga syra kolleger, ni bråkar aldrig och det finns inga tulliga ögonblick.
Ja, nu kanske jag får skit för detta, men jag håller med.
Men, vad brinner ni mest för?
Idag sitter vi här med Niklas Ahlbeck, som är vd på ehandel.se och även den norska motsvarigheten.
För alla oss som jobbar inom ehandel så är detta lite sajten som man klickar in på fyra-fem gånger om dagen och ser om det har kommit upp något.
Jag vill inte säga skvaller, för givetvis är det en nyhetssajt, men jag tror att såsom min flickvän använder sina flöden för att få reda på kanske lite goa detaljer ibland, och lite smygskvaller så använder jag nog e-handel lite grann för branschskvaller, jag tycker det är kul.
Välkommen till podden Niklas, är det en hemsk beskrivning?
Tack så mycket, roligt att vara här.
Nej men det är väl inte hemsk beskrivning, vi bevakar ju branschen på gott och ont, så vi försöker få med det mesta.
Så det är lite det som är tanken, även fast vi försöker vara så professionella som vi bara kan.
Ni vill inte gå hela vägen till TTM med bara en rad nyheter?
Precis, tanken är inte att vi ska vara en skvall och blaska, men branschmedia tänker vi oss.
Kan du inte ge oss en liten kort intro om dig själv, bara så vi vet vem du är?
Jo, absolut.
Niklas Ahlbeck heter jag, bor utanför Lund i 37 år, med mina två barn, Lilja Ludvig och fru Micaela och trivs bra med livet.
Jag har tidigare inte jobbat inom media innan e-handels.se, så det var faktiskt nytt på media, utan jag kommer från e-handelsbranschen själv, har drivit e-handel i 15 år, lite drygt.
En nischad, liten e-handel som sålde hemma tandblekning.
Så ganska nischat område.
Men startade den när jag utbildade mig till ekonom i Lund för många år sedan.
Det var egentligen för att se hur det var att driva bolag.
Och på den vägen var det.
Så det var himla kul att bygga upp ett eget varumärke.
Det gjorde väl att jag skaffade mig ganska bred kunskap.
Lite om mycket, brukar jag säga, inom branschen.
Och sen jobbade jag faktiskt en sväng med försäljning inom dryckesbranschen.
Det var lite där jag kände att jag hade två anställda vid ett tillfälle på min e-handel.
Men jag kände ändå att det blev lite ensamt efter man outsourcade den biten och ville komma ut och träffa mer folk.
Så jag fortsatte driva e-handelsidan om och började lite mer med försäljning.
För jag gillade det där med siffror.
Du måste ju berätta vad e-handeln omsatte här på sin peak.
Vad låg det att snudla?
Det var strax under 400 miljoner, så det var en liten e-handel.
Ganska nischat som sagt.
Men vi var bland de första att lansera vissa hemma-tandblekningsprodukter.
Idén kom från USA när jag var över där och pluggade.
Jag plockade med lite produkter hem, skapat eget varumärke och började snurra den på dåtidens bloggar kallas det.
Hur gjordes den rekryteringen då?
Om du hade en tandblekningssajta så började du jobba lite med försäljning.
Kom det någon sen och sa du e-handel.se kan du inte kan inte du rodda vd-rollen här?
Det känns ju rimligt.
Nej, riktigt så var det inte.
Jag sökte jobb och kom in på e-handel.se och började jobba med försäljning och blev ansvarig över det.
Det var väl det som var min väg tillbaka in i e-handelsbranschen.
Sedan blev det lite mer operativt ansvarig att vara med och utveckla våra event.
I början på detta året egentligen så fick jag ta över skutan efter tidigare väder i Johan Svensson.
Så jag har varit här drygt tre och ett halvt år nu.
Är det konstigt att gå från rollen som vanlig knegare till vd?
Blir man sedd lite annorlunda då?
Helt plötsligt slutar folk prata med dig i korridoren eller hur?
Hur känns det?
Nej, men det tycker jag inte.
Jag gillar att vara en del av teamet och vi är ett väldigt litet bolag.
Så vi är ganska, vi har bra samarbete.
Och högt i tak har vi också.
Så det är verkligen ingen som tror jag.
Känner så i alla fall.
Men det är klart, det har varit en snabb utveckling.
Känner du dig som en ledare?
Det vill jag säga mig som.
Det vill jag nog säga redan innan.
Att jag ofta försöker driva på saker och axla nya projekt.
Så det är väl det jag ibland känner som drivkraft.
Att jag vill sträva framåt.
Kan du för...
Om det finns någon härute men ehandel.se, vad är det egentligen?
Vad innefattar hela konceptet?
Vi har en ganska brett scope egentligen, men som du säger, de flesta vet att vi är branschens nyhetssida.
Det är det som är grunden till allt vi gör.
Anledningen till att vi är marknadsledande är just branschmedel för just ehandelsbranschen.
Men vi strävar ju efter bara den centrala punkten i branschen.
Vi har länge varit lite av ett community där vi erbjuder lite av varje för att kunna gynna ehandelsföretagen.
Så vi arrangör ju de här branscheneventen då för att utbilda, inspirera, nätverka.
Sen har vi också något som heter ehandel deals, som är ett medlemskap hos oss där vi har upphandlade avtal på tjänster, till exempel för små-
och medelsteoriörhandlare, och framförallt där man kan spara lite pengar på tjänster som man behöver till sin ehandel.
Som vi har framförallt, jag vet inte om jag får säga det faktiskt, men det är ett av Sveriges bästa D&L avtal.
Det är klart att du får sälja, det är ju för fan era tjänster.
Det är väl bara...
Du måste ju sälja in.
Du kan ju inte säga att det är ett av de sämsta avtalen.
Nej men, på riktigt så är det faktiskt.
Vi hade en konsult som satt och kikade på hur bra avtalet faktiskt var.
Och det gör inte fixa sådana avtal längre.
Så jag vet inte om D&L tycker det är så bra att vi går ut med det.
Men där kan man spara mycket pengar i alla fall om man skickar med D&L idag.
Så den typen av tjänster.
Så vi försöker stötta e-handlare och branschen så gott vi kan i Brottestor.
Jag tycker det är kul att det måste ni väl ändå ha som säljargument på sidan.
Du verkar, nu ser ju inte alla dig men du ser nästan såhär lite besvärad ut över om du sade något hemligt.
Men det måste väl ändå vara hela säljargumentet, måste väl ändå vara att det är ett bra avtal.
Jo men så är det.
Jag vet inte om vi har lyckats förhandla till oss ett lite för bra avtal där kanske.
Jag vet inte.
Det är länge sedan.
Okej.
Så där ska man hålla i det som när man sitter i sådana här gamla gymavtal eller telefonavtal och så är det 99 spänn på livet liksom.
Det är bara att ligga kvar och bara vara nöjd.
Så är det.
Jag tänker på det här med du sa att ni ska vara någon sorts mittpunkt och det är lite community och sånt där.
Vad är det, alltså ibland jag har haft med till exempel Björn här på BGA och Joel på Partykungen och sånt där.
De låter ju som att de pratar om någon svunden tid när alla kände alla och det var liksom ett starkt community.
Nu för tiden känns e-handeln som någonting som 9000 människor som sitter i sin källare hemma hos mamma och pappa sitter och jobbar med.
Jag fattar att det inte är så, jag jobbar ju själv med e-handel såklart.
Men är community-känslan lite död?
Jag vet inte om man kan säga att den är det.
Men det var ju mindre tidigare.
Jag var ju inte riktigt, även fast jag har drivit e-handel länge, så var inte jag riktigt med i den community-delningen.
Jag deltog inte så pass mycket då.
Men jag kan tänka mig att många som gjorde det då känner så.
Sen tycker jag själv att man ser den här, om man får kalla den inre kretsen i branschen, som ändå är med på alla de här olika branschträffarna och eventen och nätverkar mycket, mycket mer än många andra.
Men såklart har branschen blivit stor och utvecklingen har ju skjutit i höjden.
Så mer eller mindre kanske.
Upplever du själv att ni kanske fokuserar lite för mycket på ett gäng e-handlare som är de här mainstream-namnen som alla känner till?
Jag tycker att vi försöker liksom bevaka hela branschen.
Det är ju faktiskt det som är vårt syfte.
Men vi kan inte bevaka alla företag.
Det är fysiskt omöjligt.
Så vi vill ju såklart ha mycket läsare på sajten.
Och då är det ju ofta stora varumärken som många vill läsa om.
Men sen försöker vi lyfta även de här små nischade e-handlarna.
Så jag tycker vi försöker få en bra mix.
Vad är det liksom som driver, det är lite intressant det här, vad som driver klick eller intresse.
Kan ni se deras siffror, att ju större ett varumärke är omsättningsmässigt, desto fler klick driver det.
Eller finns det vissa udda varumärken som bara poppar ut, de kanske bara omsätter 5, 10, 20 miljoner, men ändå är det jättemånga som är intresserade.
Finns det på det sättet?
Mm, jag skulle säga att det är både och.
Jag tror redaktionen är ännu bättre att svara på den frågan.
Men de senaste åren har det framförallt haglat konkurser.
Och det har ju drivit läsare, framförallt.
Så det finns både små bolag som driver läsare men också stora.
Men det är de här stora kanske och stora föreningar inom stora bolag som engagerar många.
Skulle du kunna ge något exempel på ett stort bolag som alla skiter i och ett litet bolag som alla är intresserade av?
Nej det vet jag inte, jag tror jag passar på den frågan.
Ingen bryr sig av Dustin längre.
Nej det var du som sa det.
Jag tror att marknadsmixen är det som vi står för, att man ska kunna få sig den här breda kolen över hela branschen.
Inte på en hand full specifika bolag.
Jag har ju träffat er på e-handel.se, jag var med på något av era event, jag tror det var E-meet, tror jag det hette i Stockholm.
Och för disclaimer här, jag har ju till och med tagit en öl med några av er.
Så då har jag ju hört att ni är ju inte helt, hur ska man säga, humorlösa, utan ni kan ju faktiskt le och skratta ibland, som människor, trots att ni driver nyhetssajt.
Är det jobbigt ibland att alltid behöva hålla sig till det här pressetiska, alltid skriva korrekt, eller hade ni önskat att ni kunde slappna av lite grann ibland och bara få ha lite kul med det?
Där, men det tycker jag vi har.
Jag tycker vi har kul.
Vi människor, vi också, vi har väldigt högt i tak som sagt.
Nej men det var väldigt trevligt.
Vi gillar ju det, liksom att umgås med våra kunder och våra läsare.
Det är därför vi arrangerar event.
Vi är därute, vi skapar relationer.
Det tycker vi är skoj.
Sen hoppas jag att vi inte uppfattar som jättepretter.
Haha, vi får göra någon sorts poll på folk och se vad de tycker.
Ni hade en e-handelspodd, jag vet att det är ditt fel att den lades ner tror jag.
Ja, men det stämmer.
Vi måste som alla bolag prioritera saker som vi gör.
Vi körde ju det e-handelssweppet där en runda och det var jättekul.
Det kanske är så att man plockar upp den längre fram, men vi hade andra fokusgrejer som var viktiga att lägga tiden på.
Förhandla D&L-avtal?
Ja, till exempel.
Det är bättre att du gör podd, Joel.
Okej, jag tänkte att du sa att redaktionen hade bättre koll på siffror och liknande.
Men ni är ett ganska tight team.
Vad gör en vd för ett, vad kallar ni det, för mediahus?
Vad är din roll?
Vad sysslar du med på dagarna?
Som sagt, vi är ju ett ganska litet bolag.
Jag gör lite av det mesta, skulle jag säga.
Jag är inne och fingrar lite överallt.
Framförallt så gillar jag kundrelationer.
Jag kommer från försäljningssidan.
Jag engagerar mig en hel del i försäljningen och operativa verksamheten.
Tillsammans med marknadsavdelningen hjälper vi till att planera våra branscher vänt och har själv mycket kundrelationer och försäljning.
Med redaktioner till marknad hjälper jag till att driva e-handelsplus som vi nyligen lanserat.
Sen alla våra partnerskap från poddar.
Du har din podd på vår sida och sen har vi en jobbsida med e-commerce recruit.
Vi har ett nytt samarbete med e-handelsmäklare till exempel.
Det finns att göra.
Finns det en konflikt där i att, Sverige är ju väldigt litet och e-handelsvärlden är ännu mindre.
Om du säljer in till exempel reklamdealer eller liknande, då kanske det ofta är, jag bara gissar efter vad jag har sett på er sida, då kanske det är marknadsföringsbyrås eller SEO-byråer eller plattformar.
Då måste ni ändå hålla er lite halvväl med dem, samtidigt som man vill vara en granskande nyhetssajt.
Vad går gränsen där?
Ni har inte ett oändligt underlag av folk som vill betala för att synas på en sajt.
Du är inne på det lite, och visst, Sverige lite så, men jag vill inte säga att reklamannonsering är svårt för oss för att vi är nischade, utan det är snarare tvärtom.
Reklamannons är lite svårare i de här utmanade tider, när företag får mindre marknadsföringsbudgetar och så, men vi är ju långt ifrån vinklad media.
Vi har en väldigt tydlig linje mellan redaktionen och den kommersiella avdelningen, som jag är lite mer involverad i med sälj och marknad.
Så vi får in otroligt mycket tips, både till den kommersiella avdelningen, till mig personligen och framförallt till vår, vi har en tips-mail, tips-äta-järna.se.
Men det är 100% redaktionen som måste göra en bedömning om det finns nyhetsvärde.
Det finns ingen annan på kommersiella avdelning som har någon möjlighet att påverka vem det skrivs om.
Det är lite så det måste vara om vi ska kunna vara en geopartisk media.
Men vi får absolut höra ifrån våra kunder och partners ut på event och vi blir grillade, varför skriv ni inte om oss?
Så jag bara, men då får ni komma med lite nyheter.
Det är liksom så att skicka pressmeddelande där man lanserar ny kollektion eller om man vill berätta om sitt företag.
Det är like it or not, det är ingen branschlighet.
Då har vi de här annonseringsformaten i stället med sponsrade inlägg som man kan köpa sig synligt för rätt målgrupp.
Så man måste se på sina pressmeddelande med lite oberoende ögon, är branschen intresserad av att läsa om det här eller är det egentligen ett bolag som tycker att detta är en nyhet?
Så där sålas väldigt mycket.
Okej, ni har liksom ingen overlap i vad ska jag kalla det, reklam, kontra redaktion.
Utan man tar sina egna, okej, det låter rimligt faktiskt.
Skulle du kunna smyga in en liten artikel i flödet om du vill?
Om man verkligen fjäskar för dig?
Nej, verkligen inte.
Försöker folk göra det?
Ja, det är många som försöker.
Alltifrån att man tror att man har ett kundmöte, till att någon egentligen försöker få oss att skriva om dem.
Så nej, det kan jag verkligen inte göra.
Julius och redaktionen, teamet där är ju benhårda och det är ju så det ska vara.
Så det är vår styrka vill jag säga.
Får du alltid reda på vad som ska publiceras innan det publiceras?
Nej, helt frönt.
Jag bara tänkte, har du någon gång varit med om att ni har ett riktigt stort reklamupplägg på G och så kommer det ut en artikel om Sveriges sämsta SEO-byråer och så råkar den byrån vara i topp som du skulle göra reklam.
Det händer.
Ja, fan vad roligt.
Det händer, det händer.
Precis, vi skriver ju om alla möjliga.
Vid vissa tider på året så sitter vi i stora förhandlingar med annonskunder och se dem inför nästa år och ibland så skitsa i en affär för att det händer någonting på det bolaget och det skrivs om det.
Då uppskattar man kanske inte det och vill inte annonsera oss.
Då får det vara så.
Vi bevakar branschen.
Ja vafan, det får man ju skylla sig själv lite.
Okej, är det så känsligt?
Det kanske beror på vad ni skriver, men jag upplever inte att ni kör sådär stenhårt mediedrev som vissa andra tidningar gör, utan det är ändå hyggligt tillbakahållet.
Det matas inte tio artiklar om att man har gjort fel, utan det är ofta en eller två.
Nej, absolut, vi är ju inte på den uppdraggranskning grävande journalistik, utan vi bevakar.
Har du blivit en syn, jag har frågat detta tidigare till dem som är journalister och redaktörer och liknande, så Camilla Bergman och Elin Rothstein här, om de har blivit syniska människor här med åren eftersom folk kontaktar dem med en baktanke.
Känner du att du har blivit sån att om någon skriver till dig på LinkedIn, kär ska vi inte ta en kaffe, så tänker du, fan.
Alltså det händer ju att folk kontaktar en med och har en agenda liksom så.
Men jag vet inte.
Man får försöka säga igenom det ändå när vi finns här för branschen.
Och skulle det vara så vid de tillfällena så får man försöka förklara för den personen att såhär jobbar vi.
Men vi får ju mycket pitcha.
Och det är ju också en ingång för oss att visa att vi jobbar med till exempel annonseringsformat.
Och det är inte alla som har koll på vilka olika sätt som vi jobbar på eller att vi arrangerar.
Ni införde ju det här med betalvägg för, nu vet jag inte, kan det vara två månader sedan, tre månader sedan, något sånt där.
Och tidigare har ni faktiskt varit helt öppna, vilket varit väldigt skönt tror jag.
Och det måste ju ha drivit väldigt mycket mer trafik.
Jag gissar att det gick ner när betalväggen kom.
Men måste alla mediebolag alltid ha betalvägg?
Är det bara SVT som får ex antal miljarder som kan hålla öppet?
Alla andra måste gå till betalvägg.
Är man körd annars?
Ja, utvecklingen har gått åt det hållet.
Precis som vi lanserade Yrjande Plus för någon månad sedan.
Även fast vi inte låser allt idag utan vi låser 70 procent.
Så kom det nog som en chock för många att vi började med betalvägg eftersom vi har varit en gratis tidning sedan 2009.
Men tiderna förändras och utvecklingen i branschen har ju gått åt det hållet.
Idag har de flesta någon typ av betalvägg.
När man tänker efter så är det ju faktiskt ganska rimligt med tanke på allt det gedigna arbete som faktiskt görs av redaktionen.
Så även fast många nog tycker att gratis är godare och bättre, så har vi valt att lägga oss på en prissättning som är avsevärt mycket lägre än vissa av våra närmsta konkurrenter.
Även fast vi anser oss mest nischade på justerande området.
Men jag kan inte svara på det, men det är klart att det finns medier, men vi vill också utveckla oss själva och kunna erbjuda en bättre service framåt.
Och detta är ett steg i ledet för att kunna göra det.
Så vi har ju fått jättemånga som har gått med nu i Ärande Plus, vilket är kul, var på någon månad.
Och det skapar ju nya möjligheter för oss.
Så vi hoppas ju att man ska kunna se det som så.
Att man lägger en liten peng ifrån sitt bolag för att kunna få den här branschbevakningen på ett smidigt sätt via oss.
Och sen ska vi ju göra allt vi kan för att utveckla den här prenumerationen med värde.
Och komma inom kort och börja lägga till ytterligare djupgörande innehåll bara för prenumeranter.
Ja jag tänkte säga, när ni gjorde den här betalväggen så var, givetvis blev folk lite sura i forum och sånt där.
Jag blev också såhär, vad fan har hänt här, jag ska in och läsa nu.
Ska jag, det kommer jag att årekosta, det var ju som du säger, det var ju högst överkomligt.
Men ni fick lite kritik, att ni gör inte såhär jättemycket intervjuer kanske, eller stora analyser, utan det är mer sammanfattningar av vad som har kommit ut för nyheter under dagen.
Är det en rimlig kritik eller är det någonting som ni, du sa här vi ska komma med lite mer utvecklat material till prenumeranterna.
Är det för att folk har klagat eller är det för att ni känner att ni måste stäppa upp om ni ska ha en betalvig?
Vart ska e-handel ta vägen?
E-handel.se menar det då?
Ja precis, jag såg också den kommentaren på Facebook när vi lanserade.
Det är klart vi tar rörelse av kritiken.
Vi finns här för branschen så det är klart att vi lyssnar.
Även fast vi kanske inte håller med till 100 procent, och kanske också tror att en del av det kanske skrävs i frustration.
Nu var det inte särskilt många kommentarer men det var några stycken.
Det uppstår lite frustration kanske efter att en sån här tjänst har varit gratis så pass länge och börjar kosta pengar.
Självklart har vi, som alla andra medier, har redaktat, men vi får väldigt mycket förståndsinformation skickat till oss.
Det är faktiskt det vi uppmanar folk att göra.
Vi lägger också mycket tid på Sveriges största e-handlare och den typen av listor.
Vi går igenom extremt mycket årsbokslut.
Vi går igenom en lista på 8000 bolag inför varje år med bokslut.
Det är väldigt mycket jobb som ligger bakom en stor del av artiklarna som vi skriver.
Sen får vi mycket av den här första handlingsinformationen med stora odd-mål i konkursen, till exempel Ad Libris senaste förvärv och Black Friday.
Folk kommer till oss med sina siffror.
De ger inte till alla utan de kommer till oss.
Det är det vi vill för att vi ska kunna vara först och vi ska kunna vara den branschmedel man benar sig.
Jag tänker två frågor där, en lite kortare och en lite längre.
Den korta är, du sa att ni går igenom typ 8000 bokslut här varje år.
Hur mycket hatar ni nya alla bolagstjänsten på en skala 1-5?
Det får nu redaktionen svara på.
Men den har varit bättre.
Och om man nu vill synas och se er, och säga att man inte är ett av de här bizarra bolagen som alla vill läsa om, utan man är liksom en normal e-handlare som omsätter 15 miljoner och säljer, jag vet inte, stolar.
Det är liksom inget jättespännande e-handeln i sig.
Hur ska man utforma det här, eller hur ska man kontakta er, eller hur ska man liksom hitta ett redaktionellt värde i din egen nyhet?
Det är jättebra frågor liksom, och den får vi hela tiden.
Och det är ju oftast så att desto mer nichat kanske, desto mer intressant kan det ibland vara att läsa om.
Men vi försöker...
Ju mer nichat e-handel eller ju mer nichat nyhet?
Ibland skriver vi om nichat e-handlare, för att det finns ett intresse i branschen att läsa om.
Men att skriva till oss, så är det ju det här att skicka in till tips-mailen och försöka...
Är det en nyhet så släpp det till oss först.
För då är det större chans att det plockas upp av redaktionen.
Då finns det ett värde för oss också att kunna vara först.
Och sen då, de här oberoende ögonen, man måste sätta på dem glasögonen och säga att är detta någonting som branschen vill läsa om?
Eller är det bara jag själv och vårt bolag som tycker att detta är en nyhet?
Så det är väl egentligen tips på hur man ska tänka när man skickar in till oss.
För att man ska hoppas att det ska plockas upp då.
Det måste ju du ha sagt 2000 gånger.
Tänk med oberoende, är det här intressant?
Och ändå gissar jag att 90% av era mail är precis skittråkiga mail.
Har du något tips för de här människorna?
Vad är intressant för alla?
Det är ju stora händelser.
En ny stolserie är det intressant?
Det kanske är intressant för det bolaget och den nischen i sig, men det kanske inte är en branschlighet.
Så man måste tänka så.
Vad är folk i branschen intresserade av att lära sig om, läsa om och inspireras av?
Så lite åt det hållet, tror jag, man ska tänka.
Jag har varit med i E&R.se tre gånger eller något sånt där tror jag.
Jag vet inte, men när jag släppt bokslut så har jag maillat Nilsåse.
Förra året så fick jag en lång artikel där jag hade rubriken ultrapissigt.
Är det en bra idé att använda ett vulgärt språk?
Det är en svår fråga.
Vi vill ju såklart att vi ska få läsa, men vi vill inte ha clickbaitartiklar.
Det är inte syftet heller.
Men vi vill ha lite högt i tak och så, så att vi ska kunna förstå mig rätt, men en liten gnutta humor ibland, för att det också ska bli lite lätt.
Så man får ha glinten i ögonen tror jag.
Varför sätta det i relation?
För att bli omskriven blir ju på ett sätt som reklam, eller det nås ut till folk, och framförallt eftersom det egentligen ofta blir lite grann som ett företagsreportage.
Om man inte känner till e-handelsen tidigare så blir det ju som en inforuta om det bolaget.
Hur mycket läsningar har ni på en artikel, eller vad pendlade emellan, vad är det?
Vi har 100-150 000 unika läsare i veckan på site.
Så hur mycket på en artikel kan jag inte riktigt säga, för det är väldigt olika.
Men där ligger vi i trafik och du var inne på det tidigare, vi har faktiskt inte tappat så mycket sen vi började låsa.
Vilket är faktiskt väldigt intressant.
Exakt vad det beror på kan jag inte riktigt svara på än, men vi gjorde det testet i Norge tidigare på vår sajt, Nethandel.no, och har inte där heller tappat.
Där löser vi allt och har gjort sändning i februari i år, och vi börjar ha lite trafiken.
Så med de här läsarna, 100-150 000, så säger vi, vi brukar säga att det finns 10-15 000 bolag i Sverige som sysslar med e-handel.
Men var gränsen går är ju ganska luddig, det finns en massa olika typer.
Men vi anser oss nå hela branschen, mer eller mindre, på ganska daglig basis.
Så mycket mer siffror än så är ganska svårt att få, men det är det vi...
Där ligger vi.
Kan ni se att folk klickar bort från sidan mycket snabbare då?
Jag tänker att man går in och så stoppar man och så bara, nej, fan det var slut det.
Ja man skulle kunna tro det, men jag vet inte, folk gillar nivåer, rubriker och...
Man kan ju läsa en del ändå innan det.
Ja exakt.
Så folk, vissa kanske är nöjda med det, uppenbarligen då eftersom de är kvar och läser sås, vilket vi tycker är jättekul.
Och sen vill man då ha den djupa insikten så är det ju e-handel plus i så fall som man får.
Nu sa du clickbait här och jag kommer bara, apropå absolut ingenting, gå över till diskussionen om era konkurrenter, till exempel Breakit.
Det har ingen koppling alls till clickbait.
Men de är ju lite i erat område och kör lite mer, ja men kanske startup och sås och liknande, medan ni kör, vad ska man säga, ni kör mer e-handelsgrejen.
Och de tar ju fram rätt mycket artiklar eller listor som kan liksom karakteriseras som clickbait.
Varför jobbar ni inte på det sättet?
Du behöver liksom inte snacka skit om Breakit, utan jag bara menar, varför har ni inte den approachen att ni har breddat lite grann och varför jobbar ni inte mer med den sortens drivande trafik då?
Ja precis, vi tycker att Breakit är jätteduktiga på det de gör och även Market.
Vi alla skiljer oss lite åt.
Som du säger, Breakit är mycket bredare än vad vi är.
De har valt att gå den vägen, lite mer startup och tech och även e-handel då.
Och Market, lite mer mot retail och detaljhandel.
Men vi heter e-handel.se och vi vill göra det som vi är bäst på.
Det är just att vara inom e-handelsnischen.
Sen får vi väl se hur branschen utvecklas framöver och vi med den, lite så.
Men jag tycker det är skönt att vi har lite olika områden att verka på.
Det är därför också Breakit kanske, de har lite fler läsare än vad vi är.
Det är för att man är lite bredare kanske.
Men vi väljer att vara mer nischade och ha fler e-handelsbolag som läser hos oss.
Båda ni jobbar ju med lite event och ni jobbar med en del kringtjänster.
Är det för att själva nyhetsrapporteringen i sig är en för liten affärsmodell för att gå runt för Aftonbladet sitter ju liksom inte och trycker event.
Jag bara undrar, vart är det därför?
Vi vill ha lite olika ingångar på branschen och vi vill också kunna nätverka med branschen på ett bra sätt.
Så vi erbjuder till exempel våra kunder som annars har både fysiska möjligheter att träffa e-handlare på event, men också digitala och varumärkesbyggande sätt.
Så vi tycker det är en väldigt bra kombination att kunna göra både och.
Och sen såklart det finns ju större mediasajter som inte gör event, men det finns rätt många olika typer av mediasajter som gör olika typer av branschevent.
Och vi har valt att gå den vägen.
Dels för att vi tycker det är himla kul och vi tycker, det verkar i alla fall som branschen uppskattar det.
Och sen är det inte världens mest lönsamma affär med event, utan det är ganska svårt.
Och speciellt de här tuffa åren som det har varit.
Så vi gör det ju lite för att stötta branschen och för att vi ska kunna vara därute fysiskt också och träffa alla.
Men är nyhetsrapportering världens mest lönsamma affär?
Nej, nej men det är det ju inte.
Vi har ju haft ett tidigare tillväxtfokus hos oss.
Och det var det fram till i år faktiskt.
Och vi har byggt verksamheten efter att vi skulle växa, snarare än att vara lönsamma.
Men vi har fått nytt fokus inom koncernen här.
Med lite olika strukturella förändringar.
Så vi fokuserar mycket på lönsamhet idag.
Och det är väl event och annons, och även då är ämne plus viktiga steg för att vi ska kunna nå lönsamhet helt enkelt.
Om vi säger, du som vd då, och du nämnde i tidigare att du har ett visst säljfokus och det är lite den världen du kanske har kommit ifrån och liknande.
Men på ett sätt, vi kan komma sen till hur e-handel.se kanske ska växa framöver, men ni har ju också en begränsad tillväxtmöjlighet.
Det är ju inte som en e-handel till exempel som bara kan trycka på och expandera.
Då drivs man ju av det, så som jag till exempel drivs av tillväxt och tycker det är kul.
Men ni blir ju per definition lite mer, efter att ni har nått en mognad så är det svårt att växa kanske till en större målgrupp eller en större, då får ni gå in någon annanstans i något annat land.
Men det är också en jätteapparat.
Det är inte som att skicka ut treprodukter i ett annat land.
Kan du tycka att det är lite tråkigt?
Nej men alltså för tre år sen så hade vi en bra vecka på 40 000 läsare.
Och idag snittar vi nästan upp mot 150 000 läsare förra veckan, trots att vi är snart inne på jul, så löver vi på 112 000 unika läsare.
Och det är efter att vi låser 70 procent.
Vilket effektivt sätt att säga till mig att du har fel Joel.
Ja men lite så.
Jag tycker att branschen utvecklas så snabbt, så vi vet inte vad vi kommer vara om några år.
Vilket är väldigt spännande, och vi kanske kommer göra mycket mer av det som branschen vill ha, eller det som vi tycker.
Vi borde kunna erbjuda mycket mer av denna expertis som vi sitter på i vårt nätverk till exempel.
Och det är något som vi ser över just nu, om vi kan göra.
Vi körde ju nyligen igång med det här e-handelsmäktiga samarbetet med vår gamla vd Johan Svensson som driver det tillsammans med deras vd Peter.
Det är en rolig satsning på ett utrymme i branschen som saknas lite.
En serieus aktör som bara jobbar med att köpa och sälja e-handelsbolag till exempel.
Det finns mer sådana grejer att göra, likt jobbsajten då att man kan gå in och kolla jobb i branschen hos oss där som vi gör tillsammans med e-commerce recruits.
Så jag tror att det finns många områden kvar som vi inte riktigt är.
Men det kommer vi till.
Varför gör ni inte dem redan, jag fattar att ni ska vara lönsam och allt sånt där men bara fan kan, varför gör ni inte allt sånt redan?
Varför har ni inte avtal med typ 800 olika leverantörer inom allt som er kräver?
Varför har ni inte stora utbildningsportaler?
Varför har ni inte betydligt fler event som uppstyrdar på alla möjliga sätt från kunskap till att man träffas tio personer i en stad.
Varför har ni inte tre olika poddar i stället för ingen?
Varför har ni inte, jag tycker bara ni är ju en mötesplats.
Varför inte...
Så är det ju och man vill ju göra så mycket man bara kan.
Men det handlar ju om resurser.
Vi är inte så många på e-handel.se och vi kan inte göra allt.
Men vi är inte del av en stor koncern.
Vilka är det som äger e-handel.se idag?
Eller Fmedia.
De har väl lite pengar.
Det finns ju resurser.
De är ett större biolog.
Sen sitter vi i Helsingborg och är lite mindre biolog.
Så det är klart att vi stöttas av dem också.
Men vi har varit lite frånkopplade från koncernen tidigare eftersom vi sitter lite långt ifrån.
Nu håller man på att hitta fler synergier faktiskt.
Vilket är ganska intressant.
Så mer samarbete över gränserna där faktiskt.
Men när får vi se alla de här satsningarna?
Ja, det är svårt att säga men vi tar ett steg i taget.
Vi kan inte göra allting på ena samma gång liksom så.
Vi måste hitta lite lönsammare modeller.
Men fler av de grejerna som du säger med liksom utbildningsportal och så.
Det är fullt möjligt att vi ska kunna göra sådana grejer.
Jag tänker också på, du nämnde att ni sitter i Helsingborg och du är ju lundare.
Är inte det lite weird?
Det kan inte vara jättemånga nyhetsbolag och liknande som inte sitter i Stockholm.
Jag tycker det är trevligt, jag sitter ju i Mörnlöke.
Men det är trevligt att någon inte sitter i Stockholm, men det måste ju vara en nackdel.
Ja, men det är det ju kanske lite, eftersom de flesta av våra kunder sitter också i Stockholm.
Men varför sitter ni i Helsingborg?
Det skapades där och alltid funnits i Helsingborg.
Helsingborg är ju lite av, det finns ju en liten e-handelshub i Helsingborg, för de som inte vet.
Men självklart är allting större i Stockholm.
Är man verkligen en e-handelshub, om man måste säga att det finns en e-handelshub där, för er som inte vet.
Ja, exakt, det är inte så stort.
Vi pratar inte på rås eller så.
Jag menar den där lilla staden som ligger halvvägs mellan Göteborg och Jönköping.
Om ni inte spöar den lilla staden där det alltid händer, då var det fan.
Det är många som känner till.
Men vi har ju lite medarbetare som sitter i Stockholm också, på kontoret på LF Media.
Så vi är ju lite 50-50 i Skåne-Stockholm.
Och det har funkat som en bra mix för oss.
De är mycket dyrare i drift.
Nej, men det vill jag inte gå in på liksom.
Nej, fair enough.
Jag tänker på, om vi tar dig som person, det är ju som du säger, det finns ju ganska många olika vägar kanske bolaget kan ta eller vart ni kan försvinna.
Vad är liksom din passion?
Vad är det, det är liksom inget löfte till någon och det är ingen det ni ska gå med.
Vad är det du brinner för i det här jobbet?
Jag gillar ju det här att bygga nätverk och relationer.
Det är som sagt mycket av det vi gör på Erna.se.
Vi försöker koppla ihop branschen och hitta synergier där och inspirera och bidra till att branschen utvecklas.
Det är lite därifrån jag kommer försäljning med relationer och nätverk.
Det är det jag gillar, hitta nya samarbeten, bygga verksamheten ut efter det.
Hitta saker som kompletterar bara.
Sen gillar jag personligen att bygga team.
Tillsammans skapa en jättekul arbetsplats som man trivs på.
Det gillar jag, kunna vara högt i tak.
Det tycker jag vi har lyckats på i handel.
Jag tänker som sista fråga här, men jag gissar att ni har en intern chattråd, typ Slack eller Messenger eller Discord eller vad som helst.
Jag tror det är Skype faktiskt.
Skype, oj det var du ändå.
Hur rädd är du för att det ska publiceras, allt som skrivs där?
Nej, det är jag inte så rädd för.
Ni håller det clean där, ni snackar aldrig skit om någon eller flynare åt något.
Nej, helt clean är vi verkligen inte, men det handlar om att Skype...
Hur ska du formulera detta nu Niklas?
Nu måste jag fundera lite även.
Redaktionen, jag tror att valet av sådana här interna kanaler kom från redaktionen från början, tror du eller ej, men det handlar om att det skickas mycket GIFs via Skype.
Det är redaktionens kommunikationsspråk ibland.
Man kommunicerar via GIFs till varandra, men vi skriver inte...
Jag förstår att du är där och gräver att vi skriver skit om folk och så, och det gör vi inte, men vi har väldigt högt i tag att gälla oss själva.
Jag förstår.
Niklas, stort, stort, stort tack för att du var med i podden och tack för att du ändå är så pass öppenhjärtlig.
Det uppskattar jag verkligen.
Ja men kul, det var ju jätteroligt för mig.
Tack.
Fan vilket effektivt sätt att säga till mig att du har felgjort.